regardez le contenu du smartphone de son
conjointe sa partenaire ça peut être
tentant c'était légal en revanche oui un
terme à anglais qui existe pour cette
pratique ça s'appelle le snooping Julia
le snooping
40 % des Français ont déjà regardé dans
le téléphone de leur conjoint 5% le font
régulièrement on les interroge les
Français faut changer de code non
c'est un peu plus radical mais pourquoi
pas alors pour le profil des coupables
les femmes sont les plus actives Xavier
44% pratique le snooping contre 30% chez
les hommes et chez les jeunes ça explose
ils sont même 57%. et qu'est-ce qu'on y
cherche chez bah d'abord le contenu des
messages privés sur les réseaux sociaux
mais aussi le détail des followers avec
qui sont partenaire est ami sur les
réseaux sociaux
ont découvert quelque chose dont il
n'avait pas connaissance en tête des
découvertes des conversations suspectes
ambigu voir explicite
et puis ensuite les femmes découvrent
fréquemment que leur conjoint consultent
des sites pour adultes quand merci elle
le découvre en fouillant
ils sont nombreux à apprendre que leur
partenaire a dépenser de l'argent sans
qu'il le sachent qui arrive en tête des
découvertes c'est un peu cliché ça m'a
amené à comprendre pourquoi les gens
s'intéressaient aurant série parce que
pour le coup il y a pas de processus
d'identification moi je ne peux pas être
endurant en série j'en suis sûr j'en
suis sûr on en est tous c'est pas pareil
alors que moi a priori
coup de carabine bien placé le poison un
poison
peut-être on en est capable vous en êtes
capable Christophe
il y a quelques semaines encore elle
était invitée sur les plateaux de
télévision pour raconter son histoire
mon mari est mort de façon inexpliquée
l'année dernière le 4 mars cela fera un
an pour nous il avait 39 ans on a tous
été sous le choc
médiatisation le moyen aussi de
promouvoir son livre intitulé et tu avec
moi un ouvrage sur le deuil destiné aux
enfants qui ont perdu un être cher
dédicacés à son mari il y a un peu plus
d'un an dans leur maison
Eric me rend pleine nuit après avoir
dégusté un cocktail à base de vodka
préparé par sa femme rupture d'anévrisme
me dit-elle à leur entourage mais
rapidement la police a des doutes
courries a essayé de changer l'assurance
vie du couple pour en être la seule
bénéficiaire et Eric aurait confié à
toutes ses proches qu'il pensait que sa
femme avait déjà tenté par deux fois de
l'empoisonner les résultats d'analyses
pratiqués de l'autopsie démontre que son
mari serait mort empoisonné il aurait
ingurgité 5 fois la dose mortelle de
fantanyl un puissante antidouleur or
l'enquête a prouvé que sa femme s'était
justement procuré ce type de médicament
peut-on auparavant auprès d'une
connaissance elle lui aurait acheté deux
fois des cachets on lui demandant je
cite des trucs comme Michael Jackson qui
a succomber en s'en souvient à une
overdose de propofol la police pense
avoir établi le mobile d'humeur qui
avait engagé une procédure de divorce et
le couple se disputait sur un
investissement immobilier de 2 millions
de dollars aujourd'hui la jeune femme
est en prison dans l'attente de son
jugement vous avez fait une autopsie
déjà
[Musique]
très intéressant
par exemple on croit que les poumons
c'est tout petit en fait c'est tout
grand il y en a partout
et bien oui et bien moi je préfère ce
métier là de vous recevoir
dans une j'ai pas de mon vivant
en 2012 un chercheur japonais Shinya
Yamanaka a décroché le prix Nobel de
médecine il a réussi à rajeunir des
cellules humaines adultes dans une
éprouvette et les faire revenir à l'état
enbrillonnaire
depuis d'autres scientifiques sont
parvenus à rajeunir des souris vivantes
et à prolonger leur vie de 30%. vous
voulez savoir si vous avez des gaz parce
que moi j'en ai tu as des gaz j'ai des
gaz je sais pas si c'est des gaz
intestinaux quoi je des prouts quoi Paul
on doit vous rappeler que le thème de la
soirée c'est la séduction ou c'est juste
pour rendre mal à l'aise vos petits
camarades pourquoi tu nous dis ça mais
c'est naturel
mais pourquoi tu fais ça on est à un
dîner presque parfait là on parle pas de
paix comme ça c'est tabou avec son
équipe il est en train de finaliser un
traitement qui pourrait rajeunir notre
peau d'une vingtaine d'années
en rouge on voit la présence d'une
protéine responsable de nombreux
problèmes inflammatoires
les sociologues disent le 20e siècle
c'était le triomphe du verbe avoir le
XXIe siècle c'est le triomphe du verbe
être vous avez vu
tout à l'heure
quand on lui applique notre traitement
cette protéine disparaît presque
complètement
la peau redevient semblable à celle
d'une personne de 32 ans
après ce traitement une personne de 52
ans va voir ses rides disparaître et ses
cheveux repoussés
le prix du gaz a augmenté donc il y en a
qui vont faire des économies
ouais bah du coup on va peut-être se
chauffer au fioul dorénavant du coup on
arrête de parler de paix tout ça
d'accord tu as pris un sondage et Lab
79% des Français disent aujourd'hui se
serrer la ceinture pour boucler les fins
de mois dans le détail 43% des ménages
interrogés par affirme avoir renoncé à
des produits alimentaires la viande pour
43% d'entre eux qui a découvert une
jeune galloise de 26 ans dans une boîte
de conserve qu'elle a acheté chez Aldi
un serpent
d'haricots blancs à la sauce tomate ça
partait bien un petit binz tu vois et
voilà on le voit en photo vous pouvez
aller voir sur internet chers auditeurs
et donc un serpent entier qui baignait
dans la sauce tomate de la boîte de
conserve c'est la viande
le shopping est également affecté 53%
des Français y aurait renoncé au moins
une fois durant les derniers mois 49%
ont évidé les bars restaurants et cinéma
45% ont été visité de partir en vacances
où on renonçait à partir en week-end 17%
ont même renoncé à des soins faute
d'argent merci Jean-François avec nous
un sujet inquiétant
alors non pas tout de suite